Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast at Ah, ah,
just chicken in on you.
I'm checking in on you this cause I care.
Okay.
And this time when everybody else is
just thinking about themselves in their
issues,
I'm the person that cares about everybody
else and now I'm going to tell you
about it because that's what
the world is about. Now,
the world is not about
trying to go out and go.
You don't do a good thing unless
everybody knows you did a good thing.
Here's me helping an old lady
across the street. Hang on, granny.
Look into the look under my phone while
I take a selfie of what a good fucking
person I am. Um, and then I,
then I hashtag it humble.
Um,
just had the most amazing experience
helping an old person across the street,
which I documented on my smartphone.
Hashtag humbled hashtag
learn from your elders.
Oh, I am in an extra cunty mood
today. I'm not gonna lie to you.
It has nothing to do with the hipsters.
It's got nothing to do with the
Manchurian candidate. Hey, by the way,
you know, I want to apologize
to everybody in England, the UK,
the, what else do you call it? The
fucking, uh, there's something empire.
Great Britain,
right?
Yeah.
Specifically or pacifically
depending on your education.
I would like to apologize to the
football fans of the premier league.
I've been making fun of it saying
it's fucking stupid. They, you know,
and, and, and Man City,
they'd played a bunch of shit pump teams
and they're just going to keep winning.
And this is going to be like
no excitement whatsoever.
And just when you thought this
pasty freckled Yak was right,
what happened?
Man,
city loses to the powerhouse
that is Tottenham.
Oh No, wait, Tottenham,
I could've told you fucking three years
ago they were going to lose that game.
Nothing sends shivers down the fucking
spine of football fans as they shove
fucking newspaper Rep
fish into their faces.
Yeah.
Like the phrase we have Tottenham next.
It's amazing.
Okay.
They fucking lost. So I don't know
what's going on. So now, you know,
I think Liverpool could actually tie.
Yeah.
And that that would be amazing.
Right after all of this running around
and grabbing your legs and screaming in
agony, the end of the
year, you got two champions
putting a whole new fucking meaning to.
We are the champions.
We are the champions, the
premier league, Booboo,
booboo.
Uh,
no one is fucking better except
for that other team do, do, do,
do we,
uh,
the chair and so is the other city.
I for the life of me don't understand
how you have a fucking league that the
entire world is watching and you don't,
you're not,
you're not going to have these
two teams play each other.
We are the champions done of the world,
but so was man city.
We tied as champions.
Yeah.
So then what's going to happen,
you guys are both going to
walk around in your cities,
which your championship hats for 2019,
and then you run into each other on the
fucking tube or the train or wherever
the fuck you are.
And then it's,
it's like literally like one of those
stupid fucking feel good stories on
Facebook.
So-And-So had a twin
that he was unaware of.
He's now 63 and he went to a mall on Long
Island and ran into this fucking jerk
off. That was his brother
that he didn't know. Right.
I always think that's hilarious when
siblings meet each other in their sixties
that they didn't know existed.
And now what are you going
to talk about? You know,
I had my gallbladder removed too.
You really are my brother.
You want to go play fucking catch.
Um,
I don't have shoulders that work anymore.
Okay.
You also dodged the draft.
Oh my God.
How could you not be related? So that's
what's going on right now. And I,
I tried looking up to
figure out, uh, you know,
the standings and all of that
shit in the premier league.
Every one will be champion this year.
Alright.
Standings
the same way. It can end in
a zero zero tie. You can have
two champions. Do, do, do,
do. All right, so right now
Liverpool has two more points,
but I've learned that that doesn't
mean shit unless, you know,
like how many games are left and I
gotta be honest. I don't give a fuck.
I don't, okay. I'm still rooting for
Liverpool. I'm still paying attention.
But if the end of all
of this fucking shit,
these fucking two assholes aren't going
to play each other and Man City could,
could,
I dunno,
could not win it because
they lost that totter ham.
Right. Could I get bit pip a ham
on a sandwich, please? Um, I dunno.
Whatever. You know what
I'm doing? I'm doing,
what I fucking hate people do when they
come to this country is they just come
here and they tell me how fucked up it is.
Like I as an American don't realize it.
It's like, dude, I fucking live here.
Can you stop country splaining to me while
you man spread across to me. You toxic
foreign male Caucasian.
Whenever the fuck these fucking
broads a bitching about this week.
Um,
yeah.
Anyways, there's a big strike that's
supposed to be happening out here.
I'm hoping they're gonna win
the writer's guild. You know,
these fucking piece of shit agents did.
They actually fucking started packaging
deals with them making more money than
the fucking person were allegedly
working for. It's just classic them.
And you know what they do? They go to
bed, they fucking sleep fine. You know?
You know what's funny is none of my
agents have brought this up. Like, yeah,
I mean,
I wasn't a part of it and it's despicable.
MMM.
Hey Nia, we would just say no, you haven't
been on the podcast and forever. I know.
Oh Wow.
You could not sound less. Uh, I dunno.
Missing of the podcast.
What's going on with your gorgeous,
you look in great. Thank you.
Oh,
thank you.
You know, I'm a Zombie. That's
something I know. Nia woke up,
I woke up this morning and the first
thing is says it was just like, oh my God.
Oh the sleep until midnight. And then
I couldn't go to sleep until 4:00 AM.
And you know, and you want as a husband
to be like, well that sucks for you.
But you know what that means. You got
to go get the little rug rat. I did.
I made a Waf. I came in here this morning.
She goes, I go, I go, hey buddy should go,
I want waffles. Now, the first
thing right out of the gate,
she came in with a breakfast or I want
waffles. All right? But I'm a strict dad,
so you know what I did? I went right
downstairs and I made her waffles.
That's right. Yeah. You're
eating a healthy breakfast.
What'd you say, sweetheart?
You want waffles? Okay.
Absolutely. Anything for you.
But then I did make waffles for you,
Nia.
I did not because you've been crushing
it on your diet and there's all kinds of
sugar and shit in that.
You don't need it.
And I didn't want to be the guy
that handed you the crack pipe. Nia,
this off Mike thing that you're doing
on the podcast is about as exciting as
watching Liverpool and man city not
play each other for the championship.
Everyone is champion in soccer.
If you fall down, we'll fucking stop
the game for 20 minutes, Booboo,
booboo. Um, the more you watch
soccer though, you're more,
you can see how much it hurts, you
know, and they get the spikes going.
Like most salad was on that breakaway
and that guy just basically peel the skin
off the back of his calf.
But I love that he was on a
breakaway and he kept going.
Most salad actually looks like he's like,
it looks like the Judd Apatow
of premiere league soccer.
Nothing. You just gonna walk out. No,
I was about to be like you said what
they look, they look like each other.
He's the best player in the,
in the soccer league. Yes.
Um, Nia always looking out for
me. Always looking out for me.
Did you just say
something about Tara Reid?
Um, anyways, uh,
Stanley Cup playoffs started now for
all you English people over there.
You probably Roy.
What's that?
Is that like everybody sorta just mills
around playing each other and then the
end they, you know, like whoever
has the most points wins right now.
Everybody English just like,
that's a fucking terrible,
I'm going to compound it with a
bad accent. Right way. He'll fall.
Could talk like that Mike. Um, yeah.
Started last night.
The islanders,
big win and over time over
your Pittsburgh Penguins,
OT loss, OT loss. Uh, San
Jose Sharks. I fell asleep.
I think they were handling the nights
it pretty well. It's four to one. Um,
and I didn't see what happened with
Nashville. No, wait. Yeah, that was, yeah.
Okay. Sorry. I watch. I got a kid now. I
don't know what the fuck's going on. Um,
but I'll tell you what,
as much as I have a child,
as much as I'm a dedicated father,
I still had time to go onto my little
fucking garage with my wonderful,
beautiful Gretsch broadcast to set. And
I was there. I was working on that, uh,
that Soundgarden song,
uh,
never the machine again.
MMM.
Which is a nine. I saw a site, I
figured out that it was in nine,
and then I figured out the main groove
and then that second groove where he goes
on the toms,
I can never fucking here where he's at.
So I had to watch some kid on
Youtube, play it. Um, but I,
I'm able to the whole song though, what
I love about the whole songs, it's,
it's in nine and then it feels like
it's switches, but it never does.
He's just fucking with the time.
It was almost like he was either playing
double time at first and then regular
time or he was playing regular
time and then half time,
which I think is what he's doing and
just the way he comes up with the drum
parts. Matt Cameron, the overrated
underrated for this week. Matt Cameron,
Drummer for sound garden,
Pearl Jam and a,
whoever's next band is going to be
whoever they are going to be. Um,
I don't know,
I always thought he was like wasted and
Pearl Jam that he could play all these
different time signatures. And as far
as I know pearl jam just plays in for,
you know, so that's like you got like
some fucking amazing like I dunno,
wide receiver and you just have them on
special teams. Is that what it is? Bill?
You non-musician Khan?
Who the fuck are you to tell one of the
biggest bands ever that they're wasting
one of the great drummers of all time.
You know,
I've got a lot of fucking balls first.
First he attacked the Premiere League
and now you're giving shit to fucking
whoever puts together. Pearl
Jam. Um, will they fishermen
is that they came up with Pearl,
you know what a pearls
come on and visit oysters.
I can never remember.
It is pretty amazing that we
somehow found those fucking things.
Crustaceans buried in the fucking sand
and the goddamn ocean and our stupid nosy
ass as we like the broad set of species.
You know, your fucking wife just sticks.
They're fucking nose in everything.
Everything is curious to them.
They say they're curious. It's like,
no, you're nosy. You're snooping around.
It's fucking nuts. All right. Uh,
where do pearls come from?
[inaudible] that's where he is,
right?
Why is my internet this fucking slow?
Have they just decided that
I have to buy a new fucking,
although clams and mussels can
also produce pearls. They do.
So they don't do so very often.
Everything has to be inclusive.
We're not staying more nuts in clans
and muscles aren't as good as oysters.
MMM.
As oysters grow and internal organ called
the mantle use is minerals from the
oysters food to produce a substance
called now who gives a shit?
Somebody sat and figured that out.
Somebody opened that up and found
it and was like, you know what,
I'm going to give this to the
fucking woman in the tribe.
I want to bang and it was shiny and the
other women didn't have it and she liked
him and the dude got his
fucking prehistoric dick
sucked and the trajectory of
that,
those butterfly wings flapping turned
into all that bullshit you see on TV with
Tiffany's.
You know
as a man,
if you ever produce one of those,
when are you going to get her the
ring commercials like you really dish
something should happen to you.
You should lose something.
I'm not saying physically,
but you should depth some.
We should take your flat screen away
for like six months. No sports packages.
But then again, what kind of
man who is in Dysport? Well,
a lot of them because they're
all about the fucking money.
Like these fucking
Goddamn agents out here.
What a bunch of cunts I gee, you
know, it's not the AEAs steel.
It's that you'd go to bed at night
with a smile on your face. [inaudible].
That's what kills me about
the fucking agencies out here.
They don't even have any guilt
of what the fuck they do.
Just like every other
fucking corporations. It's
just fucking unbelievable.
Okay.
I'm fucking believable. And they know
they got everybody by the fucking balls.
February's going to fire their fucking
age. Do they know? They know they did it.
You did it. Congratulations.
Congratulations. Go get
your fucking infinity pool.
You're fucking greedy.
Cons. I'll tell you,
that's not just this business at any
time. You come up with an idea, all right,
and you get in business
with somebody else.
You think that they're working with
you. I swear to God, I swear to God,
but at the end of the day, you're
going to end up fucking work for them.
Every time you think you're not the
whore walking the block and you think you
finally got in the car and now
you're the pimp, you're not,
you're fucking walk in the block for
somebody. It's fucking ridiculous.
May they all die of fucking a fucking
heart attack today when they go out and
eat their fucking surf and
turf lunches, gree cons. Um,
oh no, I can only get so fucking mad
about it. But what do you expect?
What do you expect? You know, that's,
that's what they do. It's what they do.
It's what they do.
They're all about
the fucking money.
Um,
maybe that's what artists can do to
fight back because we're not organized
enough. Maybe we should just fucking,
you know, and they still would kid.
It's not that you can say to him, Hey,
what's up? You're greedy. Current.
They'd be like, hey, how are
you just riding my may back.
Um, anyway, uh, moving on.
So the Bruins play the
Toronto Maple leafs, uh,
once again, this and you gotta think at
some point Toronto has to push through.
Will this be the year? Um,
I am rooting for those guys,
but not this series. Um, and if
they beat my Bruins and I will,
I will root for them because
it's getting ridiculous.
You know what is amazing though,
and it really just goes to show you how
nice people are in Canada on the surface,
even though it's probably arguably more
racist up there than it is down here.
And I know that that's a big statement,
but somebody has to offset Michael.
What's his face there?
Is it Michael Moore?
I remember his fucking ridiculous
cartoon version of what Canada was like.
Everybody leaves their doors
unlocked in your urine. GC phase,
gingerbread houses up there.
Jeez, I understand that.
He's too fat to actually go
and do some fucking research,
which is why all his documentaries
or just op ed pieces. But the,
that whole didn't that fucking moron.
He should go fucking interview one guy
of color who tried to make it in the Nhl
and just have him tell some fucking
stories to play in minor league hockey up
there and what people said fucking
last week to I'm on the ice. Um,
anyway. Oh Jesus. Going after
England now going after Canada,
talking about fucking broads bitch
and then us bill, what's less?
Let's let out Salvador,
the look,
if you fucking people going to be down
there, so in a close together, goddammit,
you do it rack. Um, all right,
here is another question I have.
No, so here's the thing. Um,
this goes to show how nice they are.
Surface on the surface level of, um,
in Canada is,
I remember when the rangers have been
wanting since 1940 everyone used in the
80s. Everyone was chanting 19, 1940.
So they were 40 something years in
nobody chance 1967 maybe cause it's 67.
It's just too long.
Now I'm paying 40 doesn't
have a good rhythm here.
1967.
Okay.
That's like when,
when the red sox finally won and
Yankee fans couldn't chat 1918 anymore.
So then now they just go pause. They went,
they used to be 1918 and now they go,
Boston sucks.
They turn a one syllable word to a two
syllable because they're too fucking dumb.
You can't think of a fucking
insult with two syllables.
I don't know. Maybe I, I don't
know. I don't understand.
Why isn't anybody cheating? It was
always fucking shit. Now a year,
nobody chanted 1906 and 1907 at the cubs.
But everybody chanted 1918 I got, I
gotta tip my cap, the Yankee fence.
We're actually ESPN the way they
fucking overhyped all of that,
and of course them, they didn't get to the
real, you know the real story about it.
You know what I mean? Where
it was just like, yeah,
we would just say horribly
inept franchise, and the
Yankees were not good owners.
They didn't know what the
fuck they were doing. Right.
They didn't do that and that the Yankees
were just this amazing organization
that picked Michael Jordan for
decades in a row, bottom one time,
and
no one's ever going to fucking
do that again. All right.
You got the Green Bay packers.
Green Bay packers are on their way.
They went from Brett
[inaudible]. All right. To
Aaron Rodgers.
Now an errands done.
I asked you this.
When Aaron Rodgers has done,
if they have another hall
of fame quarterback that
wins one or two super bowls
three times in a row,
I don't think anybody's ever done that,
right?
I don't think so. No, they haven't.
Nobody's ever fucking done that.
MMM.
What is amazing too is
they have three that did.
They have the greatest quarterbacks
of all time. Collectively, Bart Starr,
Brett Farve, Aaron Rodgers, who can
do better than that. Terry Bradshaw.
Ben Roethlisberger.
Then you got nothing.
We got Tom Brady in my heart.
Also says Steve Drogan drew Bledsoe.
But you know the stat
people won't allow that. Um,
Bob Greasy Dan Marino to have three.
Three is hard.
Well, let's see here. Roger Starbuck.
Nope.
Nobody else
there.
Wait a fucking minute.
God knows the bears and fucking browns.
You don't have to think about them.
The lions Bobby Lane.
That's it.
Hi.
Come on in buddy.
Yeah.
Hey. Hey. Did you like the waffles?
Yeah. Um, yeah. What are you doing today?
Come on up on the bed.
Yeah,
that's okay. Come on. You
want to hold that? All right.
I'm,
I'm talking about is anybody other than
the packers have three hall of Fame
Quarterbacks, Huh? Hell, you
want to say hello? Say Hello.
Hello? Say Hello. Say hello everybody
as she's getting shy. Um, yeah,
I gotta I gotta give it up to the Green
Bay packers in which makes sense because
they've won the most NFL titles
and super bowls. But you guys,
you guys have heard this
argument enough times. Um,
it's time for me to read some advertising.
I only got one this week.
Oh hey buddy,
it's dollar shave club.
Dollar Shave Club.
Can she not be looking at this thing?
I'm trying to avoid the screen time.
She's looking at herself, not in her bed.
Say Bye bye. Bye Bye. Yeah,
it's all done. All done.
I know you want it, but you
can't. You can't. You can't
have it. The WHO? The WHO.
What is she doing today?
You're going to music class
now.
She said remote.
Yeah, she's not happy. All right.
She's saying I want remote.
I want remote. All
right. Dollar Shave Club.
Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you
never have to go to the Stila.
That's because they deliver everything
you need right to your door and they keep
you fully stocked on what you use so
you don't run out. Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready in.
No matter what you're getting ready for.
They have you covered head to toe for your
hair, your skin, your face, you name it,
they have it, you know, it's hilarious.
Somebody's going to commit a murder one
day and then just use all the dollar
shave club products.
And you know,
what if they actually get
away with it is awful.
Is that is it will be
great for this company.
Not saying you need to be that clean,
not saying we advocate murdering
somebody and getting away with it.
We're just saying that's how you will be
clean enough to get away with a murder
if this wrong. That dollar shave
club has doubled down and embraced.
Um, and you have this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up on
products you use. You determine
what you want and when you want it.
And it shows up right at your dealer from
once a month to once every six months
plus what they're handsome discount.
The more you buy, the more you save.
Um,
and right now dollar shave club has a
bunch of status sets you can get for just
five bucks, like their
oral care kit. After that.
The restock box ships regular
sized products at regular price.
Get your start as set for just $5 right
now@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar that's
dollar shave club.com/burr.
You know what those sons of bitches did?
They actually gave me a little
old gym bag. Green and white,
like the money they're making,
right? It has my initials on it.
It's great old school Guy Shit.
And I opened it up and there was a
bunch of ping pong balls in there.
I think that's, I dunno. So you'd
stuff doesn't smell. I have no idea.
But I was looking for my favorite
product that they have is the one wipe
Charlies. You know what I mean?
That's like the poor man's but a,
it's like toilet paper.
Two Point Oh so you know,
you don't fucking leave let with a
ticket tape parade still on your fucking
asshole. I'm sorry people, I didn't
mean, I didn't mean to be this.
So Mr and Mrs Shave Club is listening.
Why don't you help all freckles stock up?
Maybe I can get a fucking membership
and stop being such a fucking cheap
pastored here.
Um,
[inaudible] boom, boom, boom. One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine by guy digging, digging, digging,
digging, digging. Um, anyways, uh,
Paul Versey, I love poverty
and you know, something.
He had one of the most inadvertently
hilarious tweets last night,
which I am going to give him shit about,
uh, Paul versus on the road right now.
And I'm so proud of this guy. He's,
he's doing his first like serious,
like headlining tour across the
country. Right. And you know,
if you got somebody opening for you,
okay,
okay.
And you're like,
yeah,
bringing them around the country
and you're not a fucking asshole.
You want to see that person
grow into a headliner,
which sucks for you because eventually
you won't work together as much,
but you know, you're not going to
sit there and root against, you know,
I'm sorry this isn't coming off as
sincere as I wanted to to cause a muscle
clicking on his fucking website,
loading tour dates. All right,
so this is why he's going to be, he's
got the punchline in Philly. April 11th,
12th the 13th.
He's at Raleigh Improv on the 18th,
the 19th
and uh,
and the 20th all you people down south
don't sleep on him just because he's
fucking a New Yorker.
Then he's at the New York Comedy Club
on the 26th and the 27th of April.
All right. Uh, I got to
tell you, I saw him at, um,
Gotham comedy club and he was stretching
because they're waiting for Seinfeld to
get there. And I just watched, I
watched him and it was just, I was like,
there it is.
That man is ready.
He is now officially a
headliner and all you got,
it's just people have to discover
that. So he's learning, uh,
it's Kinda cool to actually talk to him
cause I remember being where he's at,
where he's like, you know, certain areas,
they know who he is and he does great.
And then you go down south
and nobody knows who you are.
Same way for the southern
comic comes up north.
It's like you went to a
different country at first tell,
everybody starts to know who you are.
Imagine Ron White probably had that issue
at some point during his career before
he, uh, became the
superstar that he is. Um,
so catch Paul Versey now and you can say,
I saw him when I saw him
when, uh, but anyways,
he had this hilarious tweet. He's
always talking shit. He goes,
I haven't smoked a cigar for 17 days,
which I'm very proud of him. And then he,
then he writes, tell me I can't
do 30, which is fucking hilarious.
Not only because there's people out
there trying to get off phentenol and
there's people evidently getting sold
into slavery in Libya and all he's trying
to do is not smoke a fucking
cigar and a Jacuzzi for a month
that stay strong, Paul. But what I
love is he goes, tell me I can't do 30.
Almost like he was trolling people on the
Internet and everything that I saw for
the most part was negative.
People were sending him pictures
of cigars or they just write gay.
And it just, I don't
know. It's just like you,
it's like you walked into a boxing
ring with your chin out. God,
I date and punched me in the fucking Chin.
They just mean the internet is just mean.
You don't go to the Internet for support.
Um,
but he hasn't smoked a cigar and 17 days.
And evidently he now thinks I know
him in his head. He thinks he's doing,
he's like what Reggie Miller used to do.
The Knicks,
like he's just buried in threes stealing
the inbound pass running past the three
d other side of the three point
line and hitting another one. Um,
but I am proud of him too,
cause that's what, you know,
I'll be honest with you to all the
cigars. Paul is not smoking. I'm smoking.
So I got to kind of lay off. Um, but
I'm just not feeling like I want to,
cause that's like my only advice
I really have right now. Oh,
freckles is coming up on 140
days and no fucking booze.
Um, 20 goddamn weeks.
And I got to be honest,
in much as I bring it up to you guys,
I always bring it up to you guys.
I know you're sick of it. I just bring
it up to you cause I want, I want to,
I want to be held accountable.
No, I seriously, I just want this,
I want to keep going with this thing.
So I said I'm doing a
fucking calendar year,
January 1st to December 31st and I'm
actually thinking of going to my birthday
next year.
MMM.
I Dunno. I get weird with this shit.
Like now it's like, all right. You know,
I don't want to like,
I don't want to end the streak.
Yeah.
Tell me. I can't fucking make
it to 140 days people. Um,
anyways. All right. I think that's going
to be the podcast here for this week.
Congratulations to all the football
fans in Europe of the premier league.
You must be going absolutely crazy right
now knowing that there's an incredible
chance is that,
uh,
there could be two champions
this year or maybe there isn't.
I'm trying to look at.
My F is for family script that I have
to read here in an hour. The table read.
I'm just going to get there early I
think cause I can can read this shit.
Yeah,
it won't open for me. Um, anyways,
episode nine everybody this time next
week we're going to be reading episode 10
and then seasoned number four has been
written and we still have to do all the
punch ups in the editing and all that.
That takes another fucking nine months.
But you know the big stuff,
the big heavy lifting is out of the way.
All right,
well that's it and podcast.
All right, it's done.
But there's going to be a
little musical interlude here.
Um, and then we're going
to play your greatest hits.
Another half hour bonus of a
greatest hits Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast from, uh, earlier this year,
10 years ago. I don't know when I
started doing this things. All right,
have a great weekend. Your cuts go
[inaudible]
call for Z
of course was saying Babe Ruth was the
greatest baseball player of all time.
And then he said all the usual shit.
He basically repeated shift
that he heard on TV, the,
he played at the dead ball era.
Right.
And a law head was also trying
to tell me, you know, yeah, he,
and I was just saying,
listen,
I'm not saying he's not one of
the great players of all time,
but he's not the greatest of all
fucking time for the simple fact.
He didn't play against the greatest.
All right?
He played in a segregated
league with the Pedro Martinez,
the Mariano Rivera's.
Okay. The Josh Gibson's,
they weren't allowed
in the fucking league.
He didn't have to compete against Reggie
Jackson even to have to compete against
these guys.
They weren't allowed in the league.
He was playing and basically
a softball league. Okay.
We're the top third. What I
would say would make, you know,
would make the major league baseball
nowadays. Okay. But I get it.
You've got to think like two thirds
of them won't even fucking been there.
Then they tried to do that shit.
Well, Bill, it was only 10 teams.
There's three teams now. Yeah.
And there was all solely fucking
2 billion people on the
planet. Now there's 7 billion.
All right, so I'll, I'll,
I'll knock off like I'll give him an
extra 10% on his fucking numbers then
like, give me a fucking
break. All you gotta do,
do he play baseball when
people died of tuberculosis,
he played baseball. Like there
was a hit song, but at the time
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and that song was written in the 1890s
and everybody thought it was too fucking
crazy. What, what is this
devil music? God dammit. She,
what happens when you add them off
the plantation? They get up here.
They couldn't even handle it. Bad
APP APP. App. APP, APP, App yet
[inaudible] he played baseball.
That was a hit. Baba Du, Du, Du,
Du, Zara de de de, de Beauvoir.
Dabu Ba boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop, boop. You know,
people would just hear it and then sit
around wondering when they were ever
going to hear it again because they had
no device to play it on. Yeah. That idea.
Dabu Babu,
right.
That guy came to town and everybody
stood around him and I played,
played a fucking piano.
You see how they worked out back
then? Head, shoulders, knees and toes.
Knees and toes. Head, shoulders, knees and
toes. Knees and toes. And only white guys.
No blacks are Puerto Rican, head,
shoulders, knees and toes, knees and toes.
Those big,
dumb fucking gloves.
They looked like little people hands.
Give me a fucking break.
Not to mention Babe Ruth's. I mean they
built a stadium towards his strength.
That right field fence. Okay, you can,
you can make a cop show.
Yeah,
with two toddlers and they could do
the classic scene where the fucking cop
chases the perp down the alley and he
gets to the chain link fence and fucking
jumps over it.
You could,
you could fill net with two toddlers
with the right field fence in Yankee
stadium. The House that
Ruth built. Alright,
you backed up to catch a fly ball and
hit you like mid thigh and you fell into
some guy's lap. Right? So anyway,
give me a fucking break. All right, from
1930 [inaudible] I'll give it to you.
All right? But if you played in
the teams, he played in the arts,
she played in the 18 hundreds and even
into the twenties go fuck yourself.
All right. And I feel like
every look, every like, um,
major sport has their three stooges error.
We're one team won a bunch of
fucking championships. All right.
I love the Boston Celtics, but give me
a break. You look at them in the 1960s.
I mean, it looks like it looks like a
game being played at the y, you know,
some Christian rec league.
All right.
The fucking Canadians want a bunch
of Stanley cups when you know,
you had first dibs on any guy within a
300 mile fucking radius in a 16 league.
They had first dibs on anybody
in French speaking Quebec.
And we, we had, you know, we had first
pick, like the best guy from Vermont. Gee,
did you go on a run? It's
fucking ridiculous. Okay.
And then the Green Bay packers who were
actually the fucking Yankees of football,
you know, they, you know, they were
winning titles when the Canton bulldogs,
we're still in the fucking legal
right. Okay. Wait, am give me, come on.
Right.
Football was like a genie. I think they
play with a pumpkin back then. I mean,
give me a fucking break. All those genes,
the whole store, the history, the blah,
blah.
The only ones that I will then I will,
I will recognize their championships
without a grain of salt.
I would say,
uh,
any of the New York Yankees from like
the 1930 [inaudible] for the simple fact
they went babe Ruth, Lou Gehrig,
Joe Dimaggio, Mickey Mantle.
That's just, nobody's, nobody's
ever going to do that again.
You're not going to get the Jordan of
your error four times in a fucking roll.
All right? You're just not going
to do it. So without a doubt,
I respect all of that type of shit.
But you know,
at the inceptions of these
fucking leaks when crazy legs,
Johnson runs around googly eyes fucking
Ulysses and could give me a fucking
break. Okay. He played in the deadbolt
ever. Do you don't understand.
This guy had more devils
who was on the mound?
My great grandfather
coming out of the bullpen and all freckles
[inaudible] was that the song they played
when he came in said or Inter Sandman?
They weren't facing cut
fast balls back then.
I'm sure there was guys
throwing 90 a hundred miles
a fucking hour, but just the,
the amount of bombs that were in
that fucking league back then.
I don't really want anyone to
hear it. There was, there's a,
there's a guy in the hall of fame.
Ooh,
good luck in baseball.
He kept a section of rope that
was used in an actual lynching.
Okay.
This is how long ago these fucking people
played and you're going to sit there
and act like in the inception of
these fucking leagues. You know,
I, I look at it obviously in every
era there was a Jordan. All right,
but just like the
techniques and everything,
some of the records
that were set back then,
they didn't have a fucking heavyweight
fight. It would go on for like a day.
They'd have like a fucking,
you know, a 90 round fight.
Okay. Now listen, you're getting
punched in the fucking head.
Well what kind of technique are you using?
Phil did bare knuckle fucking the people.
I want to hear it.
I didn't want to hear all right.
The competition now is so
much more insane that I,
I just think it would immediately,
but I guess they would compete at the
same level but like just the fact that
it's now everybody gets to
compete and not to mention like,
I mean you could get
fucking fathers out there.
I try and they try to
teach their kid how to
throw a curve ball to get, you know,
get the family out of the trailer park
when the kids like six years old stunting
the growth of one of his fucking arms,
you know,
cause they live in a fucking trailer and
somebody's got a growth on their face
that they want to have again.
They want it removed.
Then are those kids going out there?
You know,
back in the day you went out and you
played catch with your little kid.
Now you go out there and from day one
you try to teach them how to switch it.
It's insane. All right, so whatever
I'm just saying, so whatever.
If you do, you guys think Babe Ruth is
the greatest baseball player, right?
It's so hard to say because all you
can go by is this guy's fucking stats.
Who you play back.
You know,
it was probably a guy better than
fucking babe Ruth, but he got polio.
You know what I mean? Having just a,
it's all right. I'm done. I'm done.
[inaudible]
wow.
Hey, what's going on? It's
built burn. It's the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
April 11th,
2011 2011 2011,
whatever the fuck I got to
say all this goddamn year. Um,
how the hell are you Joe Nye some
bright eyed and bushy tailed.
I'll tell you why.
I'm going to tell you why right now.
Cause I tried to do the
podcast last night. I just,
I just can't do it on the days I travel,
you know,
flew across this country once again
from Philly all the way out here.
And I'm like, all right, it took an early
flight, seven 30 in the fucking morning,
I'll land 10 30 la time somehow I'll take
a little old man nap in the afternoon.
You know the old man take a nap.
You know what I mean?
Will you lie in the fetal position with
your hands in the prayer prayer pose
between your fucking milk white thighs.
If you me sitting there and you bbds and
a tee shirt and black dress socks on,
faced in towards the cushion.
That's an old man nap.
Okay.
And then somewhere through what
you roll over on your back,
start breathing out your
fucking mouth and, and I just,
you know,
that's what old people do and they all
guys do you need do it right in the
fucking living room. So no one could
watch TV, just dominate in the house.
Yo man balls just hanging out
this side yet. Tighty whities
um, that was the plan.
That's what I was gonna do.
Then you always end up getting cold too.
I never understood that.
If I lie on the couch awake and
I'm not moving, I never get cold.
But the second you fall asleep, you
get, you get it. You don't Chile.
Why did you go Julie? We
just leaving. Um, AH, Jesus.
I hate myself this week.
I'm not even it.
I'm not even going to
fucking get into this shit.
How fucking on funny I was
last night on the podcast.
I try to record this in for
like 20 goddamn minutes.
I to the point I have to put up one
of the outtakes at the end of this.
I've never done that.
I want to put up an outtake of
me just quitting on a story.
Um, I'll put that up at the
end, but before I, before,
before I get into the rest of the
podcast, ladies and gentleman, um,
I've got a couple of
things I have to hype. Um,
like tonight for all you
people in Los Angeles,
I'm going to be doing a benefit for a
all the victims of the earthquake slash
tsunami. Um, over there in Japan.
I'm going to be doing it at the
Catalina jazz club. Um, tonight.
[inaudible] it's at six, seven,
two, five sunset boulevard.
Just east of Highland.
All right,
I'm going to have the Lincoln everything
up on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
The show starts at 8:00 PM, uh, it's
called cabaret cares songs for Japan.
So it's actually comedy and a,
and some music. So there'll be
some Broadway stars down there. Uh,
daisy Egan's the one who actually put it
together for those of you who are into
Broadway. Uh, she won a
Tony Award when she was 11.
Alright.
Sang at Carnegie Hall and killed it at 11.
All right, got got the fucking award
from a, who's that? That checked there?
That I said that women should still
be dressed in like a breakfast,
a breakfast at Tiffany's. What
the Hell's her name there? Uh,
the one that looks like a
little fucking a, not a rat.
Not a hamster. What's a cute little
fucking big brown? I'd wrote it.
That's what she looks like to
me. She looks like, Oh God.
I wish I could have gone on a date with
her and said that to her, you know. Ready?
She's starting to like me and,
and just look across.
Are trying to say some pepe le Pew like
Romantic Shit, you know, come here,
my little brown,
I'd wrote it.
I fuck you ever notice how
fucking racist at is Pepe Le Pew?
I never noticed I talk
about that on the podcast.
Well I don't care if I did
get a wing an hour every week.
You're not going to fucking repeat
yourself sitting in your Goddamn cubicle.
How many times you told that fucking joke?
Two guys will be doing a book.
You know,
just waiting for a new employee so you
can hit him with the same old fucking
stories. How dare you?
How dare you question me.
You motherfucker in your Goddamn
cubicle, Huh? What are you doing? Ah,
you hate yourself right now
because she ate the whole Cinnabon.
Cause you lie to yourself.
I'm going to cut it in half and I'm
not going to do it. And what happened?
You cut it in half and you
saw that sugary goodness. Huh?
Just fucking come and down in the
fucking Baker. TJ's that's on top.
Just dripping down the side.
And what you went down on it,
you went down on it like some core,
just got off a bus in a strange city.
That's what you did. Now you had
your sugar rush, you like, yeah,
I'm going to fucking, I'm gonna make
it through the whole day. Cinnabon,
the poor man's 12 hour energy.
Hey,
can somebody please explain to that
commercial to me when those guys take that
25 hour energy, whatever the fuck it
is, they take it and the guy goes, yeah,
all right, I'm ready.
And then he sits down,
puts his feet up on the
table and reads a newspaper.
I thought it's supposed to make
you go work once the deal. Oh God.
Am I going to suck on this one toe?
You know what?
Fuck you guys every once
in a while have a bad set.
I think I'm going to bond this week.
So anyways,
getting back to what I was talking about.
So I had planned on taking a nap
and old man fucking nap by the way,
strip it right down to my underwears
and sleeping on the couch like a fucking
the old man than I am.
But uh, the masters,
the masters was on and I had to watch
it because Rory Macintyre from Ireland
look like he was gonna win the damn thing.
You know?
Plus I'm always rooting for tiger, you
know, because I have issues with women.
I have such issues with
women that I actually think
that at their women meetings
where they trash guys,
they actually have like a little counter
on how many tournaments it's been since
tiger actually won in. They're
trying to sit there, you know,
it's a fucking braid.
Their Harry muffs just sitting there
is the braid their
hair, Harry must. Right.
And they're just sitting there and
going, you know why? You know why he,
I think when, because in every good
work, every good man [inaudible] woman,
I know this saying that shit.
So I'm fucking ruining for tiger.
Even though I had a bet
with Keith Robinson,
every year we bet the masters and every
year he picks tiger and then I pick a
white guy,
you know,
it's sort of fun with racism and I send
them Texas like white power and this is
a white man's game and you're not
taking over this one. We'll give you,
we'll give you football,
we'll give you basketball.
Your black people actually took
over baseball there for a minute.
Then they just stopped giving a
shit. You know? It's too boring.
I don't know what it was. I liked
that. When they do those things on, on,
on sports shows,
we have to get more African Americans.
End of the day of a baseball,
they don't like it.
You know
what the fuck?
Why are you going to force a fucking
sport that you know what it is,
is because baseball sucks as they
left. Actually, no, the Latinos saved.
What am I a def jam comic? What's with
all the race shit this week, Bill? Yeah,
but see a white person
played baseball about, Fuck
God, His jersey. I'll snug
up on his nuts and shit. Um,
do you guys see a, what's his face? Uh,
Manny Ramirez tested
positive again. Ah, sucks.
Then he just steady fucking
skid. Addled I'm retired.
I'm going to go to Spain with my dad.
I didn't like how palpate
barn was giving him shit.
I thought that was a conti move.
I get it.
You're obviously didn't like the guy
when he fucking played and your team,
but you don't have to be a content.
Throw the guy under the bus saying all
this shit that these guys are already
going to say. It's kind of like
this, this asshole here in the uh,
one of the, of those guys in the New York
Post. You know those guys, they a hours.
You are as you one of those
guys on around the horn.
That show that just makes absolutely
no sense. I don't understand that show.
I don't understand how the points work.
I don't understand why that guy who
sounds like somebody imitating somebody
stupid, you know, hosts the show is,
is always clicking. Why he's in charge
of the scoring. I don't understand it.
I don't, I don't get it. And it's always
like four guys talking at once. And uh, I,
like Wally says his name, I add, I've
got, I don't get that fucking show.
I think this guy's one of those guys
on that shelf. So anyways, if you,
if you watch the, uh, the masters, which
I've watched for the last three years,
I went to it last year, two
years ago, I watched Kenny Perry.
I'm watching this guy just, you know,
it looks like a regular guy. I'm like,
oh great,
he's going to win the masters.
And then I watched just the fucking wheels
come off the entire last day and the
guy completely chokes and I
got to tell you something.
Golf is the worst game to choke him.
You know,
if you're a goaltender in the NHL
and you let up a bad goal, I mean,
how long does that take? You know
what? Fuck, in a split second,
you let up another bad one. People bull.
Yeah, I mean what we have a bad period.
They take you out of fucking gay.
It's maybe a half hour of a life.
That's a long fucking time.
You missed the big shot.
You call the fucking time out like
Chris Weber or whatever. Right.
It's fucking over done. You
walk off the court. That's it.
I guess he gets shit for,
it's still bill Buckner ball rolls
through his fucking legs in the fan that
match wet. All right. How long did
that take dude? You choke in golf?
I guess I'm talking about the game itself.
I'm not talking about the amount of shit
that you get afterwards cause that's
usually lifelong cause I heard that bill
Buckner had to move to like Idaho was
some shit.
But what I'm saying is going through the
agony of the choke is anywhere from a
split second up to a button,
I don't know, 2025 minutes,
but in golf it's hours,
hours and hours.
It's three hours watching this kid just
all over the fucking course and you know
what is 21 years old?
I thought he handled it tremendously.
He handled it tremendously.
One point he kind of laughed and shook
his head that one hole when he was
standing in between a couple of houses.
I've never seen houses on a
golf course before my life.
That's how bad his shot was.
It ricocheted off.
His ball landed in like a kitty pool.
I'm telling you folks,
it was off the golf course. Ah,
Jesus, I suck this week. Um,
so this dish fucking rights,
uh,
his shirt was stained in the front.
Everybody shirt was stained.
You playing fucking golf in
the sun. Fucking fat. Fuck you.
Goddamn show was probably
staying when you typed this.
Listen to what this guy
said. It was staying in the
front, untucked in the back.
A little boy lost Rory mcilroy trudged
up the final holes at Augusta national
and Sunday afternoon as if
looking for somewhere to cry.
His swagger had shriveled up into, or
stoop is boyish. Smile became nod lips.
And I want to ask some anybody
else watch it to anybody.
See at any point where he was going to
cry, I thought he held his composure.
Granted, he played fucking horrific.
He definitely maybe, you know,
started to panic or whatever. I'm not a
golfer. I Dunno what the fuck happens,
but he didn't look like he was
going to cry. I hate these.
I hate these fucking sports writers.
You know what I mean?
You already have a word
count, so you gotta throw in
another adjectives in there.
He's 21 fucking years old.
And then what happens is when
something like this happens in sports,
then these fat fucks sport writers who
sucked in gym class, you know they did.
You know they were the kids who got like
the bloody nose and playing dodge ball.
Then they just start turning up
the fucking pressure. You know?
That's what sucks about choking those
because now everyone's going to be sitting
there going like,
you know,
you had that collapse at the master's,
barely had time to reflect that.
Even at the end, I thought he'd said
it. Well, he says, what's going to,
what are you, what are you thinking about
right now? And he just said, listen,
it's too early. It's too early to
reflect. I want to just happen.
Talk to me in a couple of days. I thought
it was really fucking mature, whatever.
So I support the guy. I hope he fucking,
when's his God damn thing again? But fuck,
I lost 50 bucks cause tiger ended
up having a higher score than Rory.
I just picked the top white guy.
I started watching the second day.
So then I bet with Keith and now I owe
that son of a bitch. 50 Bucks, you know,
kills me is he's just going to blow it
on another itchy sweater. All right,
let's get into the podcast
here for this week. Uh,
where the hell am I here? But by hype to
thing. Oh, another thing I have to hype.
The other thing I have to hike this
week as people have been asking me, um,
I have a date at the punchline in
San Francisco on Monday, May 9th.
And people are asking me
when the tickets go on sale.
They go on sale this Friday, April
15th. All right. That's the deal.
Go to the, uh, the punchline,
San Francisco website,
which of course I don't have that fucking
information, but you could Google it,
right? Anyways, let's talk about my
weekend. I had two awesome shows.
Had to have some shows. I did one at the
records theater and Towson, Maryland. And,
uh, then the next one I did was at
the tower, the tower theater in, uh,
Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
Legendary venue I might add.
Okay. And you know, I'm all about
the history. David Bowlby, uh,
recorded a live album,
their first tie,
Bruce Springsteen got a check for five
grand was standing up or after you stood
on that stage and performed,
um, average white band record,
their live album. Uh, the fuck is it
called cut the cake, pick up the pieces.
I can see your Pussy, lips,
whatever the fuck it's called.
Dad All was all recorded there.
So I got to go down there and become
part of that fucking history. And uh,
it was awesome,
man.
I want to thank everybody who showed
up both to the Maryland Gig and two,
the one out in Philly,
um,
Maryland Gig was amazing and then Philly
just completely took it to a whole
nother level. Um, it was just
an awesome, awesome crowd.
And uh,
actually had some lady,
some lady came up to me at the end of
the show and I had run out of DVDs.
I didn't bring enough. And uh, she was
all bummed out. She goes, you know,
my son was supposed to come
tonight but he's on house arrest.
Saigon. It's too bad. I ran out of
DVD. She's like, that's all he wanted.
He just wanted to meet you and get a DVD.
So now my liberal side,
I'm starting to feel bed and I go,
all right, why don't you know, uh,
maybe you send me an email, maybe I can
send one out to Oma, whatever. Right.
And she goes, oh my God, I would
really appreciate that. And I'm like,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
What did he do? You know,
I don't want to send it out to some
fucking pedophile. Some attempted racist,
some guy who's a steel and music online.
I'm fucking with you.
So I guess it turned out some 18 year
old kid punched his 11 year old brother.
So her son Fuck head that he is not kid.
Her son,
18 years old went over and beat the shit
out of the 18 year old cause he beat up
his fucking 11 year old brother.
And because we live in such a pussy time,
because that kid basically got his
ass kicked for doing what he did.
This kid ends up on house arrest.
Can you,
can you believe that kind of a
fucking country. Who Do we live in
where the 18 year old older brother of
an 11 year old who got beat up by an 18
year old can't then go over and kick
the shit out of that 18 year old without
sitting in his own fucking house,
missing a comedy show. You know?
So now I have to mail them a fucking DVD.
That's another goddamn branch off
a tree in the rainforest. And well,
what did that fucking kid learned? The
other kid, what did he learn that is,
because he's probably gonna have a
lawsuit, right? That is profitable.
His way of earning income is to walk
around and beat up 11 year olds who have
older brothers.
Yeah.
Oh, I tell you the hypocrisy. Um, so
anyways, I was sitting out there in, uh,
I did this gig out there and uh,
upper Darby,
Philadelphia, doesn't that sound
nice? Upper Darby, upper class, upper,
we're up on a hill. We're looking
down on the poor people. Um,
that's not what Philly
is like in Upper Darby.
It was one of the most horrific
neighborhoods I've ever driven through.
I'd never been like,
you know,
I don't mind driving through the projects
during the day because the people I
see out, I'm like, all right,
these are just fucking hard work.
And people coming off from their jobs.
It's when the sun goes down,
you know, basically any way
you're at, when the sun goes down,
that's when the fucking assholes come up.
Both in the inner city and
out in the suburbs. You know,
there's no serial killer walking around
the suburbs out in the broad daylight.
He comes out at night.
This is one of the few neighborhoods
during the fucking day. You can see,
I can't even explain it. Like, I
dunno, go Google some pictures.
Upper Darby in Philly,
it's,
it's unbelievable that Americans
have to fucking live this way.
I actually will do. My opening joke was
after driving through that neighborhood,
I was like, what the fuck is New
Orleans bitch? And above, you know,
in order to look like these,
these fucking houses they look like,
yeah.
You know the end of all in the family
when they go and down that horrific street
of houses in Queens,
that's what it looked like.
It looked like a,
except they were all rusted out and I
swear to God I thought they had like 10
roofs or something.
Yeah.
So anyways, long story short, I have
a 7:30 AM flight the next fucking day.
Oh by the way,
the reason why I got lost going over there
is because I was using my smart phone
and I'm using the little map thing and
I swear to God, that fucking thing.
Yeah.
I'm going back to maps.
The rand McNally,
you know what I liked about the rand
McNally at no point when I was looking at
it, did it shut off? Did it go black?
The screen went black and then I had
to scroll my thumb down at while.
I'm still trying to continue to drive.
The whole fucking was horrific. I'm just,
I'm,
I'm completely,
I'm going to go out on a limb here
and say we have enough technology.
What do you guys think?
Am I crazy?
Like that three d TV,
let me ask you guys,
are you re you guys really going to go
out and buy those fucking things and then
there's going to be the tipping point
where more people have them than don't
have them.
So then eventually I'm not going to be
able to see shit on my regular fucking TV.
Three d TV is to be, is it, is it not
fucking clear enough with the HDTV?
Is it not clear enough that I can see
the fucking Cartlidge inside the nose of
the fucking newscaster mean?
They kept saying that when I was
watching the masters with layers,
they go the masters then three league
like I really need to be sitting there
Bendon back.
Like I'm watching the matrix is the golf
ball goes flying over my fucking head.
You know your living room outside life
is in three d go for a fucking walk.
It's a total scam.
Think about how much you want it.
I want to tell you guys this,
right? Just think about this shit.
Think about all the shit on three d.
All right. Do you want to watch this?
Dt need to watch two and a
half men in three d like, wow.
I feel like I'm sitting
on the couch with them.
Do you need to watch the news in three d?
I'm going to tell you right now,
sports in three d is going to suck.
It's going to suck. I'm gonna tell
you right now it's, it's, it's gonna.
I already think what the
Hd TV, it's all, it's,
it's getting to the point
where it's so clear.
It's like HD is like clearer
than real life. I don't know.
It's like,
it's like a fucking acid trip.
I remember one time I was watching this
baseball game with this other comedian.
Yeah.
And we were sitting there watching
the game when HD TV first came out,
we weren't even watching the game.
He was pointing at somebody
and like the third row,
go and look at that guy shirt. Look how
fucking orange has shirtless. And it was,
it was literally an orange that
did not exist in real life.
So what happened? Everybody
bought those fucking three d, uh,
bought the flatscreen TVs.
You know,
now old people with their little
square TV from the greatest generation.
They got to go out,
buy a flat screen TV that break in there
fucking hip as they try to put it up on
top of their old fashioned radio where
they used to listen to FDA and his
fireside chats,
right?
They finally get the
fucking thing up there.
The bankers took them their entire
retirement and now you can't.
You're going to go out
and buy three d TVs.
It's going to fall down on their fucking
old heads and that's going to be yet,
please people, please don't buy those
three d TVs. It's a fucking scam.
What's going to happen with
your old flat screen TV?
What are you going to do with that?
Just going to throw it out.
It's going to end up in the ocean
is talking about this this weekend.
We're going to be able to walk to
Europe on, on old flat fucking TVs.
You don't need it is what I'm
trying to tell you. I've never,
I can't remember the last time
I fucking prayed that a, uh,
that uh, technology was going to
bomb the way I have with those,
those d fucking TVs.
All right.
And I don't want to hear
any of you fucking can send
me emails talking about the
discovery channel and how the fucking
do from the God damn rainforest frog is
going to drip off right into your fucking
lap. And if you smoke some weed, man,
how fucking cool that's going to be. And
then all the Frat Boys, who would've,
well, porno porno with three d.
What about fucking a real girl?
What about that? You know, all right,
I'm going to give you pour enough.
I will give you porno cause you know,
it's going to be great. I can't wait
for that fucking sex suit to come up.
You know,
they're working on that like a full body
sex suit is actually scientists working
on that, having mature
conversations, uh, you know,
like not snickering at all talking
about these, these fucking,
as they're developing like dissections
and basically what it's going to be.
Do you remember that,
that little onesies that Arthur funds
are rarely used to wear when he be in his
garage working on some fucking 1940s
rusted out hunk of Shit. Remember that,
that thing that he would wear it kind
of dirty version of like those jumpsuits
that the caddies were at the masters.
You know,
of course Brittany would wear one,
roll it up and have her titties hanging
out of it and talk, you know, saying like,
oops, did I just touch your Dick again?
Whatever the fuck she used to sing about.
Right. Hey, do you know
when rolling stone,
they had the top one hardest 100 artists
of all time and Madonna was like 50
something and I was going to get upset,
but I was just like, you know what,
how many pop stars can
last fucking 30 years?
But then I thought there was justice
because they had like other famous artists
writing,
like you know,
like Questlove would write the one for
prince you two would write the one for
like a, you know, fucking
rolling stones or whatever.
But I thought it was really fitting
that Brittany Spears wrote the one from
Madonna,
although it should have been lady Gaga.
She's doing a fucking songs,
right? Like fucking word for word.
She's doing a mash up without,
without Mcdonald's lyrics over at the top.
Is that what the fuck she's doing?
Anyways?
Let me get back to what the
fuck I was talking about here,
which I can't even remember.
Okay.
The fuck is wrong with my brain this week.
What the fuck was I just talking about?
Yeah.
Oh Jesus Christ. You know, so
you know what? I'm fucking Rory.
Whatever the fuck his name is,
right McElroy right now. Okay.
I had this whole fucking thing when it's
the final days of the masters and I'm
just limping my way through 18
holes of this fucking podcast.
This podcast right now is
in between those two little,
just like Rory was on the fucking
13th or the 15th fucking Hole,
whatever the hell it was. What
happened to all fat, tits,
Phil Mickelson, I wanted him to
win another one. I'll tell you,
it killed me that I wasn't
there at the masters.
If you ever get a fucking chance,
you got to go. I went last year,
I've been to a super bowl and it's never
really bugged me that I didn't go to
another one. It bugged me for
the first couple of years,
but once the game was over and I still
had two grand in my pocket and I didn't
have to go to a,
uh,
an airport and stand in line and do
that horse shit again and fly home.
It's never bugged me. But this one's
seriously bugged me that I wasn't there.
You got to go once in your life.
You've got to go down to Augusta,
but I've got to tell you to say it's
one in one of the shittiest fucking, uh,
it's not even in a shitty neighborhood.
It's just like, you know you don't,
when they show that when you drive
up and you look at the Georgia Pines,
whatever the fuck they are, when you
drive up to the clubhouse, first of all,
as a spectator, you're not allowed to
drive up there and you never see it.
You're not allowed to walk
around that side of it.
That's just for the
players in the members,
but right outside of that like a half a
mile away is like a fucking waffle house
at Denny's at JC Penney's,
just like just that shit.
Mcdonald's
ace hardware store,
the way they shoot that thing is they
shoot the masters the same way they shoot
like Elvis's house.
Like when you look at Elvis's house,
it looks like it's just
like it's in Savannah,
Georgia or something and then you go to
Elvis's house and I swear to God there's
like an, I hop like right next
door and I was like, yeah,
that makes sense.
That's why he was so fat.
He could just walk down his driveway
and go get some pigs and blankets and he
just go over there.
You know.
Was Elvis the first fat coke head.
You know, they talk about that.
Like most people do coke,
the they're not, uh,
they fucking lose weight or some shit,
you know, I dunno. You know something,
he got fat too. Before we really
had all the preservatives in there.
He was just fat on some,
what the fuck was he eating?
Peanut butter and fucking banana
fried sandwiches on his fucking jet.
Splitting his jumpsuits. Oh, another
jumpsuit bringing it back around again.
That's exactly what those, those,
those caddies got those jumpsuits a,
they all had a mission is the cake.
And they could come down on one knee.
That's what they should do. Come down
on one knee holding out the Cape.
Is Somebody fucking Putz for the master's?
That would add some excitement, wouldn't
it? All right, let's get back to Philly.
So anyways, so I got up, I got a 7:30
AM flight. All right. So I'm thinking,
all right,
that means I gotta get up at fucking five
30 return the rental car and all that
horse shit. Why don't I stay at a
hotel right next to the airport.
So my travel agent gives
me the whole list of, uh,
of options of where I can stay. So I'm
like, yeah, fine, fuck it. All right.
I checked them out and one of them is
the Sheridan Sheridan, respected name,
a very quality hotel.
I say I'm going to stay there.
And the price reflected that
it was a quality hotel. It
cost me like, oh, you know,
180 bucks or something like
that was a lot of fucking money.
So a one 99 something like
that, you know, fulfill, he,
that's a lot of fucking money considering
I was right outside upper Darby.
So anyways,
here's my travel tip for you.
Do not ever stay at the fucking Sheridan
at the Philadelphia International
Airport. It is a beyond
ghetto, Sheridan and I,
and it's so fucking ghetto that I,
I knew it was a fucked up Sharon
before I even went into it.
I pulled up and it looked fine. I
got out of my car, it looked fine.
And as I walked into the place,
as I was walking in,
these four chicks were coming out and
they just look like horse from a reality
show.
Awful tattoos on their feet.
Tidies up and pushed together these
cheap ass look stripper shoes.
And I went out though. Oh No, not,
not, not, not a bad hotel. Please God,
please. I start praying to
the travel guides. Please,
please don't let this be a bad hotel.
You know how Mike Way,
but you know at first I was
like, all right, what, what
are these like call girls?
So they just get done servicing some
fucking married business guy on the road.
Is that what they did? But it was
like 12 noon. It's like, no, no, no.
Call Girls are up at 12 noon. All right.
They already wiped fucking washed off.
The vaginas hosed them down at like eight
in the morning and now they just fell
asleep face down in a fucking pile of
glitter and they're not going to wake up
again to like five in the afternoon.
That's how it works. And they wake up,
they fucking, you know, I
dunno what they do. You know,
they put some fucking vitamin E on the,
on the ligature marks around
their neck from the night before.
Yeah.
Do you know,
you know what's fucked up about ligature?
Nobody ever uses that statement unless
somebody's got choked to death. You know?
Linkature my know what does never any
ligature marks, because you know why?
Because these girls who
are into that type of shit,
if they survive the encounter, they
fucking, they were that little, uh,
that little ass got the next day around
their neck. You know, the hoary one,
a choker.
That's what they were to cover it up.
You have to have a girl wants you
to do that once you to choke her.
I remember one time I was with
this girl, right, and she a shoe,
all this type of shit. Do you want me
to slap her in the face and all this,
all this crazy shit that,
uh,
there are all these fucking
women's shows they never address.
They never addressed the amount
of fucking women that liked that.
They like it rough.
It's fucking insane,
unless I just keep picking the
same kinds of fucking women,
but it's ridiculous the amount of
fucking broads that I've gone out with,
you know,
fucking women's Lib, fucking Blah,
blah, blah. My career comes first.
If we get married, I'm not taking your
last name, Yadda Yadda, fucking Yada,
right? Then you get them in, you
know, the fucking all pro women.
There's pro women that, and I'm making
my own money and fucking, you know,
in a couple of other fucking lyrics
from some stupid Beyonce song, right?
All at fucking horse shit. You're
going to respect me eyeball to eyeball,
the images of women on TV,
all that fucking horse shit.
And then you get them back to
your place and lo and behold,
they have a rape fantasy, you know, am
I the only guy by the only fucking guy.
So anyways, so I was seeing
this fucking broad, right?
And she's going to fucking college.
She's getting her Mba and
all that type of shit.
So this is the first
girl she ever asked me.
She told me that she wanted,
uh,
me to choker and I was like,
no, I'm not doing that.
Yeah.
And she's like, why not? And I said, well,
cause I'm not fucking gonna call the cops.
Like how am I going to talk my way out
of that if you fucking pass out and I got
my fingerprints around you,
God damn neck and your naked body.
I mean that just sounds like one
of those fucking things from,
even if you come around,
I'm going to have some sort of fucking
assault charge and then you're going to
feel guilty because everybody's going
to know because the cops are there.
So then you just going to be like,
yeah, I didn't want him to do it.
So you can somehow skip away with your
fucking integrity. I'm not doing it.
Of course I did. Of course
they did. Eventually.
But there's a technique I can't actually,
you gotta you gotta be,
you gotta make sure you're up a little
higher and underneath and you gotta you
gotta do it and then not be doing
it, do it. And then not doing it.
Don't just fucking grab it.
Like you don't grab their
next like fucking David Tyree
in the helmet. Catch you.
Don't, you don't want to
do that cause you're going,
you're going to choke him out. Uh, you
know, unless you're really good at CPI,
how the fuck fucked it ended up talking
about that shit. That's it really.
You know something?
I'm going to talk about that in my act.
Jesus said I'll bring this psychos out.
Um,
I'm going to talk about that. My Ex, you
just heard a fucking preview of a joke.
I really want to bring that up.
The amount of fucking women
they got that thing right.
They're all independent
and that type of thing.
And then you get him in the
bedroom like you want it.
They want you to get kicked the shit out
of him. But they got that, does that,
that fucking line.
They want to feel the man's
power but still feel like safe.
Yeah.
Overpower me.
But like do it in like a nice way,
but not nice, but nice. Do you know what
I made? I know exactly what you mean.
You filthy fucking whore.
Uh, all right, I have to get up.
I gotta get off this subject.
This is just going to get too freaky
to be talking about this by myself.
Uh, this is the choke 'em
out podcast, everybody. So
anyway, so I see these fucking,
just these, these whores
father didn't stick, you know,
George Foreman Grill,
Eaton fucking just,
just never had a chance
for girls just coming out.
Just never had a fucking chance.
And you know,
just dressed like fucking trucks,
doc fucking whores.
And the sad thing is,
is they think they look good and they
don't even realize the vibe that they're
putting out. They don't know any better.
They don't fucking know any better.
All right? There was a rusted out
car in their front yard that day.
They were born and they never
had a fucking chance. You know,
the only fucking male voice that was in
their household when they was growing up
was the Billy Best that the deaf,
they're fucking dad left behind.
You know what I mean? Just, they
just never had a fucking chance.
So that was my first red flag
and I was gone out. God, maybe,
maybe they use some sky miles.
Is that how they got in here?
And I just walked in the
second I walked in, I, I just,
I can just tell the caliber of human being
that was in there straight across the
board here. Alright. The
caliber a white person,
the caliber of black person,
the caliber of fucking male,
female gps can tell.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Saw some black dude,
you know,
when they get their hair braided but they
don't have enough money to fucking get
it braided enough so they got all
those little hairs sticking out of it,
you know, cause you can't see the
scalp in between the braids, you know,
it's not looking fucking right.
It's just not looking right.
The fucking white dude with
the chief Anderson little suit,
the fucking creased up Brown loafers with
this gold lamay horseshit on the front
of it. You know, shoes look like they
cost 11 bucks and I'm just going on now.
Ah, God least let the fucking
room be cleaned, you know?
So I check in the lady behind the
counter. She was nice enough, you know,
I don't know how she ended up at this
fucking Sharon and maybe she has stepped
out of line at the big a
stockholders meeting. This is,
this is there still Sheridan side barrier.
So then I go up to my room and uh,
it's weird. It had like one of the,
it almost looks like a little house.
She come walking in,
there's a door and right next to it
there's this big window for some stupid
fucking reason.
If I want to overlook half the elevators
in the fucking poor excuse for a pool
that they had. So the blinds were down,
right. So I open it up and it's a sweet,
I'm like Nice. It was a nice
room. It wasn't bad at all.
So I'm in there for like five fucking
minutes and I hear this knock on the door,
right guy fucking knocks on the door.
He was covered in foam.
So that's what it sounded like.
And I opened the door and there's a guy
standing there with his giant coffee
table and he goes, and he's trying to walk
in with this giant cocktail. I'm like,
Whoa, whoa. I go, you got the wrong room.
I didn't order a table. He goes, not, oh,
this, this tables is your, your,
your room's missing a table
like it is. They go, yeah, yeah.
The last people who are here
broke the other table. I was like,
Jesus Christ. What? Did they have? Like
a party or something? Anyway, yeah.
I thought he was going to say no.
He went like, yeah, and I go, well,
they fucking fumigate the place now. I
think everything's been just on. I'm,
you know, I'm laying in fucking angel
dust and cocaine and Shit, you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
It keeps getting worse.
Then I'm sitting there for another couple
minutes and then I just hear this lady
telling this story, right? Yeah.
They did this mother fucker fucking track.
Tell me that mother fucker can't
come off it. I said, mother Fucker,
mother fucker with a motherfucker,
and I'm like, is that it leads?
Is it at least a guest?
Is it at least the guests and I fucking
open the blinds to my window and she's
one of the people cleaning the rooms.
Yeah.
Just cursing up a fucking
storm loud as fucking hell.
Like all broke Pete,
Bro.
People are the loudest fucking people
because they live near the freeways.
They live near the subway. They used to
shouting over shits and she's out there.
This mother fucker trying to tell
me what time it is baby. Right.
And just screaming
and you know how much I curse.
Okay. I was offended and you know
how much I curse? I was just like,
Jesus Christ, can you please,
I might have kids someday.
Can you please stop cursing like that?
But I didn't say shit cause I,
I mean at that point I knew what was
gonna happen. I would've been like, oh,
I just would've been like,
excuse me, could you do me
a favor? Could you use now?
Might've, well, why don't
you Maggio business? Ain't
nobody talking to you baby.
Right.
I didn't want to go through that whole
fucking thing at her screaming at me.
Plus she was so fucking big,
she probably could've just choke,
slammed me and we would have had to
have a new fucking table in my room,
third fucking table that week.
And I'm a conservationalist is that
the right word? So I'm like, all right,
fuck it. Whatever. So I don't say ship.
So then I go out to go do my show and of
course I'm using my stupid smart phone.
I get lost. I'm driving through
upper Darby and it's just like, well,
you know,
a fucking,
the white guy driving through there
looking down at his phone and yeah,
I can't see it. Can't stay
the same where I am. You know,
I did everything but roll down
the window. Excuse me, hustlers.
Could you just stop hustling for a second?
I could just wondering if you could
directly and the direction of this theater
that I'm performing in tonight.
You know, horrific. So, uh,
I was so fucking mad.
I really got to get my temper together.
I could feel myself when my screen,
every time I had to go to make a turn,
I'm looking down at my map and the
fucking phone would go black, you know,
to save the battery. And it was always
what I needed to make a decision.
Then I would miss a turn and it got to
the point I was squeezing my phone and I
knew what I was,
I was going to take it and I was just
going to smash it down on the uh,
whatever you call that, the, the,
the fucking thing that you're
not a gear shift or I guess it is
geared, the thing, you put it in gear,
it's not a stick.
You know what the Fuck I'm saying?
I was just going to smash the screen
on that and I knew that, that I,
I had my temporary control enough
that I knew I couldn't do that shit.
So what I did was I just started
screaming over and over again,
fuck you at my phone. I was yelling,
fuck you at my, in my car yelling, fuck.
You would've found blow. That's what
my voice is all scratchy right now.
Not because I had,
I screamed for two shows is because
I was screaming at my cell phone.
So anyways, I finally ended up getting
there. I ended up doing the show.
It's fucking phenomenal.
And whenever, whenever I,
I do a show at a place like that.
MMM.
You know,
there's always some guy's been working
the theater for like 2030 years and I
always walk up to the guy, go,
you don't have to say any names,
just tell me some stories. And this guy
was telling stories about, you know,
hanging out with motley Crue back during
the hair metal days and going out to
strip clubs.
And he said he was there when guns and
roses came through on the appetite for
destruction tour.
He said afterwards he was standing in
their tour bus and they're looking out
their windshield at a sea of groupies.
And at 1.1 member, I'm not gonna
name names, looked out and said,
what's up with those two? And the
guy said, oh, that, that's actually,
believe it or not, those aren't
sisters. That's a mother.
And a daughter and I guess they were
really hot and the dude was like, oh yeah,
bring them on the bus.
Do it in my next life.
I want to be a fucking musician.
Just to have the opportunity to
have that level of groupie. Ugh,
just fucking unreal. So anyways,
so I drove to upper Darby.
He was just unbelievably depressing
that people have to live that way.
Fellow Americans have to live that
way and that we're always sitting here
fucking acting like we give a shit about
other countries and we need to help out.
We don't. All right, well we,
I mean you give a shit or I give a shit,
but our government doesn't.
We're working our way in
there to help them out.
Air quotes so we can take their natural
resources. All right. That's how it is.
That's what the fuck is really going
on. If you ever wondered why, all right,
they don't give a fuck about upper Darby,
new New Orleans or whatever. Fuck it.
All those blue collar towns that
are failing out there in Ohio,
they don't give a shit about
him cause they already own them.
So if there's any oil to be had,
they can just go in and suck
it out of the ground. Yeah.
Did that make any fucking sense?
So anyway,
so I go back to my ghetto ass
fucking Sheridan. All right.
I come walking in there and uh,
and at this point,
it's one in the morning.
Now,
if it was one in the morning
and I was at a nice hotel,
that'd be the usual thing. There would
be some people hanging down at the bar,
you know, drinking, getting
ready to cheat on their spouses.
Dress nicely though.
All right.
But because was a ghetto fucking Sharon
and I went down there and most of the
people in the lobby,
we're children running around
screaming like one in the morning,
kids just running around. I felt like I
was in fucking Atlantic city. You know,
those gamblers degenerate gamblers, they
don't fucking handle their kids. Right.
Right. So just as see a fucking children.
I mean, I was waiting for fucking,
you know,
yeah.
Yoga was missing with somebody there,
you know, gathering them like you could,
you could have had a children's choir.
That's how many fucking kids were there.
So I could go up the elevator and I,
and I get out,
get out of the elevator and I walked
back up to my little, you know,
I told you the front of the room looked
like a house and there was a door.
And then there's the window. And
as I'm looking, I'm at the doors.
I'm looking down to take out my hotel key.
I looked down and on the window sill
is a three quarter eaten chicken wings
sitting on the fucking window sill.
I got pictures to prove it.
They're all going to be up
on the m m m m podcast.com.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Is that the name of the website?
I know the name of the fucking website.
The Hell's wrong with me? Yeah, the MM.
The MM podcast.com. Uh, if you go up
there, I'll have all these pictures,
the pictures of, uh, the
tower theater and all that.
I didn't take any pictures when I was
driving through upper Darby could for
obvious fucking reasons. I didn't
want to be, you know, I just,
I would not want to be taking pictures
down there cause people either think
you're a cop or you're just
documenting their level of poverty,
which would be Fuckin and knowing to me
if I was in that situation. So anyways,
with that, that was my, Oh and then
the next morning I woke up and uh,
I dropped my car off at budget.
It was fucking hilarious.
One of these hilarious racial moments
here is I go to get on the bus,
the bus drivers, black five white guys
get on it. He asked us where we're going,
I go USA or this guy says
this, so blah, blah blah.
So we're driving in that
and he's listening to this
preacher because it's Sunday
morning and the guy, you know,
he's talking about, you know,
people need to be into Jesus and
blah, blah, blah, all this, you know,
regular Jesus Shit.
Right?
But then all of a sudden he starts
talking about Obama and around he's just
starts kind of trashing white people
just go, oh, we should be given thanks.
Did Jesus,
that a strong black man is president.
It's not afraid to stand
up to the white supremacy.
We run it in this country
and he's got it cranked
and I'm sitting there fucking and all
I did just cause I wanted to have the
laugh. I just turned around and looked at
all the other four white guys and there
everybody's just sort of sitting down
and looking at that wingtips like rally.
What exactly is the call here? What
can we say something, you know,
excuse me, we're not all
white supremacy. You know,
like what exactly is the proper response
to that? Because I thought it was,
I dunno, I, I actually thought
it was fucking hilarious.
I wish I could remember what the guy's
saying. Ah, Jesus. Now I'm fucking bomb.
And again on this fucking
podcast. All right, let's,
let's get through the rest
of the, uh, what am I going
to do? And I gotta do some,
Oh, hey, wait a minute. Fucking NHL
playoffs are coming up. Everybody.
Are you excited? Are you like me? Do you
like watching hockey Bruins? Canadians?
Once again,
we're playing those fucking cops up
there with all their championships.
Do you know the more I read
about the history of the NHL,
the less impressed with the
Montreal Canadiens? I am.
I mean I used to kind of give
him shit cause I'm like, dude,
you dominated a 16 league and they
didn't even dominate the 16 league.
It's like them and Toronto.
Montreal and Toronto basically had the
same amount of cups right through the
early sixties. I, Montreal
was ahead but not by much. Um,
and then I found out later
that the Canadian teams had,
but we know I couldn't give them shakers.
A Bruins were there too. So it's like,
well why didn't you guys do it?
And I found out one of the
main fucking reasons is,
is the way the league was set up,
any French born Canadian player,
the Canadian teams had
first dibs on those guys.
That's why they got all
the fucking great guys.
So it's like Toronto and Montreal
would just like the Yankees and red sox
fucking buying up everything.
I don't respect them.
I don't respect those championships. What
do you think about that? Montreal? Um,
and then what happened? All of a sudden
you didn't have first fucking a choice,
right? And now, look, now you
don't go on a run anymore.
You want it 93 one in 86 and that's it.
And don't even talk to me
about the seventies. Okay.
I don't want even fucking hear it because
that was still the fallout of the old,
the old system.
You had to give those,
those expansion six teams a chance to
get on their feet. And once they did,
that was the end of you guys.
So I'm not fucking impressed.
So fuck you and all your fucking cops
here come the Bruins and you know what?
Keep your fucking head up or
we're going to slam you into that.
Turnbuckle whatever the fuck they
call it again, that son of a bitch up,
they're fake. And his father cause the
worst concussion ever. Three days later,
he's at the movies.
He's at the movies.
All right, I'm just
fucking with you. Okay. Uh,
Bruins Canadians going to be an awesome
series and a carry prices playing great.
So it should be, uh, should be phenomenal.
I don't think the Bruins are
gonna win the Stanley Cup.
I just don't think we have enough guys.
And I just think that despite the fact
that we have two great goaltenders,
I just think that there's a lot
of goaltenders playing great.
Kerry prices playing great.
A Henrik Lundqvist is playing tremendous.
Uh, who else? Who else is playing
good out there? Oh, you got,
you've got what's his
face up there and buy?
Can't ever remember the fucking name.
Who plays,
who plays goalie up there in Buffalo?
Bill Murray. Is that what it is now?
We call him Bill Murray.
Bill Murray.
And then you got fucking Roberta
Lou Longo and his cousin, uh,
Theo flurries third cousin who plays
out there and fucking Pittsburgh.
I'm the worst. I can when I,
whenever I have to remember a name,
I can't remember her fucking name.
So whatever. I think it's good.
I think it's going to be a think it's
going to be great. I just don't see it.
I think I will be really happy if we
can actually make it to the eastern
conference finals.
You know,
that's my thing. This is,
you know what, Hey, I'm, I'm,
I'm, I'm beaten down as a fan.
As long as we don't go up three games to
none and then lose four in a row. Again,
I'm going to consider
this year of victory,
but I do not on any level want to
lose to the hated fucking habs.
Um, and I'm fucking with you a
bunch of cups, but not really. Okay.
Let's get onto advice this week.
Everybody. All right. Hey Bill,
I always feel like you give
great advice. Well, thank you.
So I thought maybe you could
give me some on this situation.
I was in a local shop a few weeks ago
and there was a little hottie work in
there.
Um,
I had seen her there once before and both
times she really caught my attention.
I had the urge to ask her out while I
was there, but I was too busy be enough.
And I did. And I did not say anything to
her other than some idle nonsense about
sunglasses. I was looking
at, oh, that's the worst. Uh,
the little bit we did talk though,
she seemed really cool and really nice.
My advices.
How can slash should I ask
her out without looking like,
mmm.
Coming off like a creeper, a
douchebag. I'm a good looking guy,
have a great career as an attorney. But
when it comes to ladies, I can be shy.
Sometimes seeing is that,
you know,
that's a very strong thing
that you're able to admit that.
But every guy just went,
ah,
I wasn't mad at you fucking fag go
up and say something to her. That's,
that's how guys handle. We just beat it
out of each other. Okay. We said, watch,
I'm trying to work on,
yeah.
Leah says, every once in a while you
see a girl that blows you away. And uh,
this time I wanted to
do something about it.
Uh,
all right.
All right, dude. This is what you
gotta do. You gotta, you gotta get,
you've gotta work on your
self esteem. Okay? You know,
you're a good looking guy and you have
a great career. Believe it or not,
that's game set and match.
Do you know the amount of fucking not
even good looking guys who have a shit job
and they are just scumbags,
but they're assholes who are out there
fucking crushing it every God damn
weekend cause you just had the balls
to walk up and talk to these women.
You know, this is what you gotta do.
You actually know what you gotta do.
He said you can be shy sometimes,
but you're saying you're working on it.
So there you go. Just keep working.
It looked dude, she probably light.
If you're a good looking guy
and your fucking attorney,
he actually said something here.
I'm hoping to see you.
What Caroline's in May if I have my dick
had friends can get this shit together
if they can't.
Maybe with your stellar advice,
I can even bring this hardy to the show.
Why don't you just do that?
Go in there and make her laugh.
Joke around with her on anything and just,
just fucking lay it on the line.
Listen, I'm really attracted to you.
I think you beautiful. I ever the fuck
you want to say it and just say, you know,
I think it's always good if you have
somewhere that you're going, just say,
I'm going to this comedy show I love,
you know,
I'm really into this standup comedian.
I have an extra ticket which you'd like
to go to. Women like going to stuff,
you know,
gives him an excuse to get dressed up.
It gives them an excuse to not feel
fucking guilty when they're blowing you
later cause they actually went to some
sort of ball or some shit, you know?
Oh God. Yeah. Even with
advice them off for this week,
but the essence of it is there. All
right. You already talked to her.
Just go in there again.
You're not going to come off like a creep.
I actually think that it's easier to
pick somebody up and get that number.
At least back in the day.
I have no game left anymore cause
I've been in a relationship too long.
But I always found that it was easier for
me to get a girl's phone number on the
a at the fucking Jim.
Jim's a little bit harder,
but like I do it on the ice
to get it on the subway.
Oddly enough,
I had a better chance there than I
did in some meat market bar because I,
I was never good when females had their
guards up when they knew what play I was
running. Some guys can do that.
They like the old packers.
Like everybody knew the packer
sweep was coming and they,
Forrest Gregg still fucking ran over here.
And some guys are like that.
Even when women know they got there,
they're fucking guard up and they
know what the fuck they're doing.
They could still plow through it.
They run over,
the guys just run right over those girls
like Forrest Gregg and next thing you
know,
they're laying on their backs with their
legs up in the air and they get the
Dick. I was never that guy.
I was, I snuck up on you.
I waited for something stupid to
happen that I could comment on.
And then I get the girl laughing. And
then when her fuck her defenses were down,
I'd uh, I'd wrestle her cell phone up
from per fingers. No, I would have,
I'd somehow get her number. So what I
would do is I would just go in there and,
uh, I'll just keep reexplaining this 20
fucking times, do get tickets to my show.
Right. Look at me, I'll make
a little money out of this
advice. So now you've got,
you've got somewhere that you got
to take her, take her rod, you know,
a little thinner.
The skit comedy shows,
she's already fucking laughing
halfway through my Aqi do the old,
you're laughing your ass off. Don't try
to put your arm around his shoulder.
That's old school right. You put it
right on a fucking thigh, you know,
then you sorta start creeping up
there with your fingers, you know,
like just sorta thinking about something
going pinky ring, Middle Index.
He just sort of work your way up like
an inch worm. And next thing you know,
if you're, if you're, if your
fingers are Nimble enough, you know,
you stretch out your picky, it's
Kinda rubbing right on her clit there.
Okay.
And then you get made fun of me cause you
guys are fucking walking out during my
closing bit to go bang at the fucking w
around the corner to it's right there.
It's a lay up to fucking lay up.
All right, next one. Hey Bill,
huge fan of the podcast and all your
stand up and have made all my friends big
fans of yours as well. I really enjoy the
relationship. Advice for Blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. All right.
People ask me is starting to address
the fact that I've never been married.
Why am I taking your fucking ex
advice? Right? Here's my situation.
I'm 29 recently from medical
school after a good number of years
honing my boning skills
in the free market,
I'm ready to calm down and have a
serious girlfriend. Ironically. Um,
the girl that I'm dating and wanting to
get serious with was actually my college
girlfriend and first love.
We dated throughout college but broke
up before attending different medical
schools. During our years
together. I cheated a lot,
but to my knowledge never got caught.
A big part of the reason
I was so promiscuous,
besides being your typical piece of shit,
cocky asshole guy full
of tests testosterone was
because she was very sexually
inhibited,
no blowjobs the routine conventional
positions sex about once every other day
and that just wasn't cutting it for me.
Now,
when every other key now
in every other category,
she was amazing fun to hang out with,
but still lady like carrying respectable,
educated, fashionable and extremely
beautiful. So like I said before,
we broke up for about five years and
our back dating again and the sex is
exactly the same now,
while I'm grateful that some guy didn't
completely smarter out during our
breakup, I did explain it did expect
some sort of sexual maturation,
um, blow jobs remain few and
far between and pretty subpar.
Even for a black chick. This
guy's black, by the way,
before you think this is
something fucked up. Um,
what makes it even more difficult this
time around is after banging my fair
share of broads in our off season,
uh,
my sexual prowess has grown significantly.
It's hard because I really want to be
faithful this time around and take the
relationship more seriously, but I fear
I'm not going to be sexually satisfied.
My grace fear is ending up like one of
my father's friends who I always hear
complaining about how shitty their sex
lives have become after marriage. Um,
how I should have had all my fun now and
Blah, blah, blah, stereotypical castrated,
Merryman background noise.
Uh, fuck that extra sad shit.
I'm not getting married unless I know
my wife is going to be a lady in the
streets in a freak in the sheets.
How do you like that old
African American mantra? Uh,
my question is how serious
should I take this problem?
Should I be patient and hope that I can
liberate her sexually or should I bail
and keep searching for
a god-fearing dinner?
Cooking super freak if
you don't mind asking. Uh
Oh,
if you don't mind asking Nia as well.
I'd like to hear what the
sister has to say. Oh Shit.
I should have read that to her by the way.
I'm also black.
So when you get to, is it
racist, racist, racist? No,
I'm allowed to say sisters. Uh,
all right. Um, you know what?
I really wish I read that part
of what I had her in here,
but she's not around today.
Um, what should you do?
All right. Number one, don't cheat on
her. Uh, well you should do is you should,
you should communicate this tour. Uh,
obviously not the way you just said it to,
um, oh Jesus. This is, this is tough.
I, I'd have to ask you some
questions. Let me ask you this.
Do you feel she has the potential?
That's,
that's what that would be.
My number one thing
is, ah, this is how I would do it.
All right. Fuck this. All right.
Now and now I'm back on track.
This is what I would do.
First thing I would do is I would,
I would see if she has the potential.
All right. If she's a good
kisser, if she has a good touch,
if when you're banging her, you don't
feel like you're fucking riding in a,
God did the back of a delivery truck.
The rhythms there.
She has is she has the basic tools.
Alright. Cause some people,
they just don't, they,
they're not blessed with the touch
then. Not Good. Kissers you know,
and a lot of females, not a
lot, but you know enough are,
that's another thing they never bring up.
They always talk about how guys don't
know shit in bed and you just blah blah
blah blah. But there's a lot of women out
there who they don't know shit either.
Not saying that bad or whatever,
but in some of them just,
I just never going to be good.
So if you feel she has the potential then,
then there's hope.
So what you have to do is you have to
basically what I used to tell my friends,
we used to joke around, just say you got
to tap into her inner whore. All right?
And the, there's a couple of
ways to do it. One of them.
And it's very delicate dude.
It's like one of those fucking action
movies where you'd sit in there trying to
clip the right fucking wire is, it's,
you know, eight seconds left. Um,
there's a couple ways you go about it.
Uh,
one of the ways is, well first of
all, this does a couple of rules. One,
as she's trying to open up
with you sexually or whatever,
don't ever judge anything
that she wants to, to uh,
try and don't ever make fun
of anything that she said.
It bet if she says some dumb shit,
which she's probably going to say,
cause you sound like you're way more
experienced if she's trying to talk dirty
for the first fucking time and she
says some dumb shit, do not laugh.
Simply turn her around and doggy
style and then you get your laugh up.
All right,
you got to do the quote.
But don't ever do that.
That is like someone is
never more vulnerable than
in that specialty of female.
You can't, you can't do that.
And then what she I would,
I would do is I would just basically
figure out what she's into,
try to figure out what, what some
of her fantasies are. All right.
So that that's how I would start at,
find out what some of her fantasies are.
And you start getting her down that road.
And then as you're going down that road
and you're not judging her and you're
not making fun of any, you just supportive
as she goes down that fucking road.
Um, then she'll gain confidence and
then Dan, hopefully that'll happen.
And one of the ways to kind of lead her
down the road is try to tell her some of
the shit that you're into that
you've never done with her.
Then I'll go all the way down to the road.
You know,
your five years of fucking horrific shit.
You did just always be a couple of paces
out in front of whatever sexual shit
that she admitted that she wanted to do.
So that way her shit doesn't seem as
freaky because it's a couple of steps
behind you, but you don't completely
freak or the fuck out by, you know,
talking about some German porn shit.
All right, so that, that's what,
uh, that's what I would do. All right.
And that's what I have been
doing throughout the years. Nia.
Look who just walked in.
Somebody actually asked your advice
because he will working out.
Do you want to do this? Okay.
All right. You know, what do I have?
I don't have my other microphone,
so we actually have to be over here and
let me ask you this shit real quickly.
I'll give you the basic overview.
All right. There was a guy, right?
He sees this girl, they like each other.
The heisted, the college sweethearts,
everything about her. Um, was, was great.
They have fun too. She's needs a little
under the weather here. All right.
Are fucking allergies are kicking up.
Let me hear your voice. Say Hello. Hello.
Okay. And you worked out what? A
fucking trooper. All right. Real quick.
So everything hanging out, they'd
laugh at each, at each other's jokes.
The whole shit was perfect, but then
they went to different medical schools.
All right? So they broke up for a while.
And during the, you know, the five years,
I guess this guy cheated a
lot when he was with her.
And now five years have gone
by, he got his free cow. Uh,
if you saw the look of disgust on
her face, he did all this shit.
So now he's back together with her.
All right.
And he was kind of hoping like
it's a sex was kind of lame,
like when he was with her missionary
position. Very like if you like,
if you're gonna make like a, like a
high school video on how to have sex,
the mail takes out his penis.
What aroused?
Like they were having that kind of
sex and no blow jobs whatsoever.
So now he's gotten back together
with there. He wants to be serious.
He's gotten all these,
hopefully all his bullshit out and
now he's back with their in the sex is
basically the same.
Now there's a couple of blow jobs.
So he's wondering how does he get
her to tap into her inner whore?
Should we pursue said he
pursue this relationship?
Like how, okay. How does
a guy do that? Like how,
like I said, basically how I do it. Oh,
she's already saying, give me the mic.
All right, go ahead.
Uh, well first of all,
it just because you enjoy
sex in different ways.
Does it make you a horse so she doesn't
have to tap into our inner whore?
Just more, uh, freedom sexually?
Has he tried to talk to you?
You don't need to clarify it. Okay.
I'm not saying she's a horror.
We understand this. Okay.
I felt the need to clarify.
Did he try to want to put your fists
in the air for women right now?
Okay. Uh, did he try to talk to her about
this before and she just ignored it?
I don't think he's talked to her
about it yet. So it's, you know,
it's the first step is that he's got
to talk to her. That's what I said.
Look at that.
Why don't we switch it up a little bit
and I wonder why she didn't give him blow
jobs. Maybe she just doesn't like giving
blood. Maybe she doesn't know how,
but it can be fun to explore
together. So he should, yeah,
you should ask her about
it. Just say, you know,
what's the worst is when women say
they can't do it cause they have TMJ.
And it's like, what? They don't like to
do it. Some people don't like to do it,
you know, it's not, it's not that great
for the other person, but it's like,
some people don't like it.
Some guys don't like to go down and girls,
some girls don't like to go down and
guys, it's just a preference thing. Okay.
All right. So you basically
said what? I said,
I thought you would've come in here with
some shorter that make you feel bad. No,
but I just see, I thought
I would be coming at it in
a different, more rational,
sensitive way. But she said the same
thing, Huh? Yeah. But not as sensitively.
I said all the Horse Shit.
Yeah. You know. All right. Yeah,
that's, I don't know what I
thought it was going to continue.
I don't mean it like that.
I just said in a mean way.
Can we come over here and get a hug? Get
a hug. I'm coming towards the end of the,
uh, the podcast. All right. All right.
There you go. Now get outta here.
Cause you've been, you've been, you've
been more than helpful. All right.
She just gave me the finger.
Now you know what it is,
and yet whenever you're on the podcast
and then the podcast segment ends.
I don't know how to smoothly transition
you out of here because we don't go to
commercial. Why don't I just go ladies
and gentlemen, Nia, Nia, everybody.
Thank you so much, Nia. See you
next time. See you next time.
You were great. And now what
the fuck just happened to Mike?
I hate computers.
It just signed me off and I was
on a nice little fucking roll here
and now I can't. I can't get
back into my, my, my fucking,
okay.
How is this easier? People
I want, I want people to,
now I have to go into my fucking, my
stupid apple works. All right. Here I am.
Fucking all right.
I'm going to read one more of these and
that's going to be the podcast for this
week. All right. Uh, hey bill,
I need an outside perspective.
My wife left me a year and a half ago
to go blow college guys and spend her
newly raised salary on clothes and purses.
Not Kidding.
That's what she did.
After nine years and two kids,
I found out that she had two short
affairs after each kid was born,
then left me with our five month old
baby and two year old I had been raising
without her. Anyways, Jesus, Oh gee,
I'm a year later, she finally
started trying to share custody.
She didn't have her hit her
half of daycare. I'm sorry.
People every once in a while I
go back to my bed reading habits.
Let me just take a breath here and step
back, focus. All right. A year later,
she finally started trying to
custody. Okay. So after she's gone up,
she left him with two kids to
go blow college guys and uh,
spend all her money.
She just got on our newly higher salary.
I'm a year later, she finally
started trying to share custody.
She didn't have her half of
daycare, um, bill for a few months,
even though she doubles my income.
So I told her she could pay me back.
Now the conch gets or tax return, it tells
me to fuck off. She's not repaying me.
She's going to get a car to replace
the one she totaled in a Dui.
Jesus,
where did you meet this winter?
I'm pissed off and can't blast
or in the job. So what do I do?
I'm thinking of hiring a crackhead to
spray paint deadbeat on her fucking car
from one asshole to another.
Thanks bill.
The podcast and all three cds of helped
me through a lot of tough shit by
laughing off the retarded
shit that this court does.
MMM.
All right dude. Uh, yeah. You, you
picked a winner here. This is like,
this is one of these ones that
you should ask Dr drew about. Um,
who's amazing and he would hit his half
court shot and tell you exactly what's
going on.
This,
there's something going on with her
where she has affairs right after she has
kids. I don't know what that is, but
that's triggering something inside of our,
um,
I dunno if she gets freaked out with the
level of responsibility and she wants
to, I dunno. Do a bunch get, get, go.
So her oats in a female fucking
way. Phil Might, I dunno. You know,
some, sometimes women have babies and
then they had that postpartum depression.
She has some sort of
postpartum like you know,
hedonism that she just goes out and she
just turns into the fuck fest 2011 so
what you have there,
do you have damaged goods?
There's no way you can ever fucking
trust her again. You got two kids. So,
um, don't do anything to her. All right.
This is like in sports when when
somebody comes up and slashes, Yah,
the ref never sees it,
but when you retaliate,
you always end up getting the
fucking five minute major.
This is what's going to happen.
She's going to do all this dumb shit.
You're going to hire people to do stuff
or I know you're not going to literally
do that,
but you can try to exact some sort of
revenge and I dunno if the decent person
always seems to get caught.
So I would avoid doing that.
Yeah.
This is how you get your revenge is I,
I would just focus on being a great
dad for those two kids. In all honesty.
I know that's a ton of work.
And it's easy for me to say when I
don't have any kids and I never ever bad
mouth their mother to them.
Never do that. You know,
have a buddy of yours where you can just
vent and just talk about what a crunchy
is as you're punching the bar,
but never do it in front of your kids.
Cause that's still their mother.
Eventually they'll figure out what an
irresponsible horse she is and there's
going to be,
that's going to be your great
payback is in that moment.
Not only are they going to realize what
an irresponsible whore their mother is,
is they're going to realize what
a great dad they have and a,
which is obviously going to be priceless.
Um,
and in the meantime I would
ask myself is if this, this,
this lady,
if this is the kind of person,
have you met a girl like this a number
of times is it's just bad luck or do like
every woman, every woman that
you've dated is like this.
Because if that is the case,
there's something about these kinds
of women that you're attracted to.
And as I've use that analogy, you keep
fishing in the same poisoned pond.
Uh,
I think because you got two kids that
you want to go out and go meet a winner,
I go out to that debt shit where you're
going to meet a decent girl, go out,
go take a cooking class.
I just gave are near for birthday a
fucking almost a goddamn year ago.
She finally got around to it,
a couple of gourmet cooking classes and
she went there and it's kind of like a
little scene, you know, people
bring wine in your cooking,
there's all that fucking people,
a taste and shit.
All the senses of go in that pussy
getting wet in the room. You go in there,
you fucking knock a couple out or
whatever. Join a softball league.
I don't know what all those, a lot
of boozing was softball, you know,
probably going to get
some bloated whore there.
You might want to stay away from that.
Maybe that's where you go to vent about
what a fucking whore you're wife is.
But Dude, you know what? You're a great
fucking guy. You're doing the right thing.
Is sticking with your kids and your even
supporting her even though she's making
more fucking money.
She's a loser. All right.
She's a fucking loser and she's out of
your life and your kids will be 18 one
day and then this bitch will be out of
your life. So who gives a fuck? All right.
In the meantime, yeah,
focus on being a good dad.
Get yourself in great shape.
I don't know.
Find some fucking way to do something
social. Go meet a great woman.
I can see there's plenty of great
women out there. It's just like guys,
they're out there. Go find one
and just ask them during the day.
Just be like, by the way, are you a, are
you an irresponsible whore? Because I,
I really just got out of a relationship
with an irresponsible whore and I'm not
trying to trying to do that
and talk about cheating.
Ask if they've ever cheated on somebody.
Here's another great question to ask.
Ask if their parents are still together.
That's a great one to ask.
The parents are still together.
If they get along with their parents,
they come from a strong background.
That's a good one to ask. Um,
that's a good place to
start off and that's it.
I'm done trying to be doctor
bill here for the week. Um,
our and six minute podcast, once
again, I'm going to be down at the the
Catalina jazz club.
Um,
doing a benefit for all those
people out there in Japan,
fellow human beings who also live
on a fault line just like I do. Um,
so, uh, hopefully somebody out there,
we'll do a fucking comedy show
for when La falls into the ocean,
so I'm paying it forward.
All right, so come on down.
All the proceeds will go out
to help the victims of that.
This Catalina Jazz club down on Sunset
Boulevard, um, I just tweeted about it,
uh, at Bill bird.com. I think that's
it. Uh, we got all the youtube videos.
They didn't get a chance to describe
the youtube videos this week,
but they're fucking hilarious.
Um,
some guy has a potato gun that he shoots
a bunch of pubes onto a passed out guy.
That's one of them and it just goes
from there. It just goes from there.
So I'll go to the man
podcast to watch all that.
If you want to see the pictures of the
tower theater and me working with uh,
Joe to Rosa, the teen idols sensation
from the opiate Anthony Program.
I have all of those and I have a picture
of that fucking chicken wings sitting
on my window sill just in case you
think I was making it up. Mafucka ah,
that's it.
Everybody have a great week.
I'll fuck yourselves and I'll talk to
you next week. Oh wait, I don't hang up.
Don't hang up.
I almost forgot.
I almost forgot I told you that
I was going to bring in the, uh,
the outtake from my failed
attempt at the podcast last week.
This is like a special track.
Remember that back in the day when you'd
buy like a CD and they'd say they'd be
like 15 songs,
but it would say 16 tracks and they would
just let the tape run and run and run
and run. And then you'd, you'd find
the A, that little gym at the end.
I think this is, this is the podcast
version cause I already signed off. Um,
all right,
just to set this up,
this was me last night after getting
like four hours sleep flying across this
country and then watching the math is,
and I'm trying to tell that Sheridan
story. And up until this point,
it just had not been funny.
And I think I'm at the part of
the story where the guy, uh,
was bringing the new table to,
to replace the broken table in.
And a, I was trying to explain it in a
funny way. It wasn't funny and I just,
I just fucking tapped out. Uh, and
this is the clip. Hope you enjoy it.
I'll talk to you next week.
I was like, Jesus Christ.
Then I heard an argument
between a man and a woman.
As I was walking back downstairs,
and later on that night when
I came back from my Gig,
there was a fucking half eaten chicken
wing sitting on the window sill on my
room.
I got a picture of it,
you know,
I actually, you know something, when
I knew she, I knew something was up.
When I went to check into my room,
uh,
there was a knock at my door five
seconds later, and the guy goes, oh, hey,
and he's got this big table. I'm
like, dude, you got the wrong room.
I didn't order a table. He
said, no, no, no. He said this,
this table belongs in your room. He
goes, somebody broke it here last night.
And I was like, Jesus, what
was their party here? Or
something? He was like, yeah.
I go,
well,
did you fumigate the place or is it
just all Jizan coke residue in here?
And he just left,
shook his head and left.
And that's when my ass
knew was in a ghetto
as brothers shared and baby
[inaudible]
[inaudible].